first up he is the co-founder of the
center for humane technology and co-host
of the podcast your undivided attention
tristan harris back with us
chris john how are you
sir all
right thank you for being here you know
we always have you here because you are
the guy who keeps it real for us on big
tech
so big story in the wall street journal
this week about uh facebook and you know
whenever i read these stories this one
was about how they changed their
algorithm i'm always thinking
how much do our robot overlords really
control us because i honestly i feel
like a [ __ ] hamster yeah like
they changed an algorithm and people
acted completely differently yep
what was the algorithm and what was the
change so
the wall street journal published this
is the largest
my understanding is the largest set of
internal research about facebook's
effects on society that were known
inside the company and that they
deceived from the top and it has effects
across the gamut from suicidal increased
suicidal ideation in girls teen girls uh
mental health issues in teenagers body
image issues and specifically the thing
that i think you are both most
interested in which is the way that it
makes political parties more negative so
they made a change that basically said
the things that generate the most what
they call meaningful social interaction
which was actually just code for what
generated the largest argument so you
know people focus on the posts on
facebook but it's the comments whatever
generated the most big long comment
threads that stuff got shot to the top
and what that resulted in was a
basically rewarding political parties
for being more negative and they found
evidence in poland spain taiwan india
where were political parties who used to
post you know
you know regular facts about policies
they wanted to do they couldn't get
attention they had to go 80 90 negative
to get the same attention so it's the
anger it's the anger it's the anger and
outrage that gets the eyeballs but who
could have predicted this it's not like
anyone was saying that you know
but i mean the the facebook defendant
would say it's just a town square and
the people in the you're blaming them
for what the people in the town square
are doing and they can't help it that
people are kind of shitty now
i mean that's sort of the bottom line i
i don't think facebook that's facebook's
fault what's different is that it is a
town square that's a little more like
you ever been one of those movie
theaters where the seats actually move
because you're watching this movie where
the runaway train yeah it's like that
it's as if the town square actually was
not passive right the town square is
actually affecting how people perceive
what they do it's it's part of the
problem it's part of the equation yeah
well i think the companies try to defend
they're just holding up a mirror to
society so if you have those crazy
people who are going to post crazy
things we're just showing the mirror of
european society but the the problem is
that these things are not a mirror it's
more like a fun house mirror it selects
for whoever says the most divisive thing
and that's what shoots up to the top so
we have a trillion dollar market cap
company with the most powerful super
computer in the world pointing an ai at
your brain being like what's the next
fault line in society that will
maximally outrage your limbic system and
whatever that answer to that question is
and it's using trillions of dollars of
compute power to figure that out it puts
that at the center of attention for the
entire world you let society run through
that for 10 years and you wonder why
does it look so insane and so we've all
it's almost like we've been through this
massive civilizational bad trip i mean
we we have an entire mind warp that's
taken place and you know it doesn't have
to be this way but the business model of
engagement that getting whatever it
takes to get people engaged is the key
to the equation so you seem to be saying
that the biggest problem is not
censorship
because we do expect facebook to do some
of that and we'll get into that because
some of the things they've censored i
don't think are right yep like the wuhan
lab but before we get to that
uh
you're you're seen to be saying that the
problem is is the bigger problem is this
engagement issue yeah it's it's the
anger it's not censoring stuff it's that
you want these people to be chicken
fighting each other all the time and
that's why and that's i've said it many
times people have to stop talking
politics all the time we never used to
do this we didn't care what kid we went
to third grade with
thought about brett kavanaugh yeah
exactly
and we shouldn't
you